the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care whose have busted
that starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight update video there are some
new and very interesting developments
coming out of Belfast Northern Ireland
this week as I'm sure most of you know
by now Game of Thrones filming further a
season has been well underway for
several months and things are just
starting to heat up after King's Landing
said they spent roughly 55 nights
shooting what could be the great war for
the final season of Game of Thrones but
now they had shifted their sights onto
the brand-new set they had built in
Belfast which will be King's Landing it
appears as if most of if not all of the
entire cast and crew have moved to this
location but something very interesting
happened on Instagram the other day and
this could reveal something very
important in terms of the endgame actor
well scolding posted this photo of
himself on his Instagram account and if
you look at the sign just above the
doors you can see that he's standing in
front of a hotel that is located in
Belfast in case you don't know Belfast
is basically the headquarters for Game
of Thrones Titanic Studios is there
which is what they used a film almost
all of their scenes indoors for those of
you who don't recognize this actor I
guess I should tell you exactly who he
is because he doesn't look exactly the
same way as he did when he appeared in
the show this man was none other than
Rhaegar Targaryen
he played Rey guard during brans
flashback when he saw Rhaegar and Lyanna
getting married the actor has since
deleted the photo from his account which
means he now realizes he does have
something to hide because of course once
he posted this it started to create a
buzz on Twitter and now YouTube I guess
ol welfare didn't realize that almost
every Game of Thrones fan is an amateur
detective and you can't post things like
this online without people investigating
it's probably not a coincidence that he
has arrived in Belfast so at the same
time that most of the Game of Thrones
production has moved to this location as
well so what does this mean
for season eight well I am hoping this
means we will get more flashbacks from
brand that involved rhaegar targaryen
who is one of the most important
characters and their story although he
doesn't even appear that much now we
have to ask ourselves if Rhaegar is
appearing again what purpose could he
possibly serve at this point in the
story
what could bran see that involves
Rhaegar that would help move the story
forward for years one of the most
popular theories was that bran would see
a flashback of the battle at the Trident
this is the famous location where Robert
Baratheon and Rhaegar Targaryen fought
till the death while Liana was at the
Tower of joy Rhaegar was on the
battlefield preparing to face off with
Robert Baratheon who Liana was betrothed
to with his war hammer in hand Robert
Baratheon slammed it into regards chest
which sent all of the red rubies from
his armor flying into the river this
blow to the chest was devastating and as
Rhaegar Lay Dying he whispered a woman's
name which I believe was Liana's I
wasn't sure if they would ever give us
this flashback but I know most of us
would love to see this the reason why
I'm mentioning this now is because of
what the plot leaked actually said I
don't know how many of you listen to me
read the plot leaked a few weeks ago but
in that leak it says bran has a series
of visions and all of the visions
related to Rhaegar Liana and most
importantly Jon Snow bran went out to
the weirwood tree what Tyrion Sam and
the maester to see if he could find any
information on Azure 'hi the last hero
or the prince who was promised and all
of the visions he had pointed to Jon
Snow the lake says bran has a flashback
of the tridon but it doesn't show Robert
and Rhaegar fighting it showed a man
laying facedown in the water which was
supposed to be Rhaegar then it showed a
black silhouette standing in front of
the night king right as they were about
to face off it also said bran had
another flashback on the Tower of joy
but this time Liana was sitting up in
the bed and she was accompanied by
Rhaegar Targaryen and Rhaegar was
telling Liana that their son would be
the Song of Ice and Fire now obviously I
don't know how much of this plot leak is
true but I find it very interesting that
the actor who plays Rhaegar is now in
belfast which means he could be there
film more scenes and maybe just maybe
this leak could have gotten some things
right I don't want to go too far down
that rabbit hole just yet
but I think this just adds more evidence
to it possibly being true I do have an
idea but I'm not exactly sure how they
could pull this off I'm wondering if
bran can somehow show John the truth
about his parents as we all know John is
on his way to Winterfell when he still
has no idea who his parents actually are
bran and Sam know the truth but how will
they get John to believe them John could
be in denial although I think John does
trust Sam and John definitely loves his
brother bran even if he is a completely
different person than the one he last
saw now I know this idea is gonna be
very tinfoil II but I think it would be
interesting if bran could take John into
the weirwood net and show him a
flashback of Rhaegar and Lyanna it would
be really cool if bran could put one
hand on the tree then one hand on John
and show him some things that way or you
know what
now that bran is the three-eyed Raven he
should be able to send people dreams
just like the old three-eyed Raven did
to bran and possibly many other
characters in the books bran should have
the power to do this too I'm actually in
the process of making a video about bran
Joe Jenn Bloodraven the night king and
the chosen of the forest so I won't say
too much about it in this video but I
think bran may be able to show John
something somehow but let's open up the
discussion in the comment section what
do you think about this actor showing up
in Belfast do you think we will see
Rhaegar Targaryen again and if we do
what kind of scene do you think it will
be put all your comments or theories
down below because I would love to hear
them I want to thank everyone for
stopping by to check out this quick
update video I really appreciate that
I also want to thank all of my patreon
supporters I hope you have a great day I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]